i want to i want to pull up this uh this
tweet thread from
zack seward who is the i believe he's
the editor-in-chief at quartz who posted
one of the most deceptive falsely framed
articles i've ever seen such a lie it's
a really good example of the problems we
face yes before i start this by
criticizing the mainstream media for
lying to you i want to point out that
there absolutely are conspiracy
theorists and lunatics and cult members
on the right they exist sure but they're
not vc funded they don't have investors
who are giving them all of this money
there are some small right wing outlets
conservative outlets that do get funding
but they're not nearly as bad as this
they they wrote a story we ordered the
same gun used in uvalde here's how easy
it was
he says it was just like ordering
groceries click checkout done
he's getting roasted for this seriously
because while in the piece it does
mention you have to go through a
background check and all that stuff the
way they frame it is incredible take a
look at this he says
at no time where we ask for proof of age
or of a clean criminal record both of
which are legally required to buy a
firearm
that will happen when we pick up the gun
at our local license dealer that's right
the headline is everything
here's how easy it was they're trying to
convince you not only that but he goes
on to say it was an assault rifle he
says some people don't know how easy it
is to go online and buy an assault rifle
he didn't buy one though he did not buy
an assault rifle it's just
a misrepresentation
and this is what leads people who are
traditional liberal or trusting in the
news into believing
wrong information so what this tells me
is he's not actually interested in
having a thoughtful conversation it's
about an agenda right so very clearly
this is about
creating this drum beat this hysteria to
ban not just this gun but really all
guns right so it's it's a war then on
guns and if if in fact that's the idea
then the question becomes particularly
from that outlet that we know as a lefty
outlet
why do they want to remove all guns is
it really just about trying to save the
kids in school i'm not so sure that's
true i think most people would say
there's probably another agenda here so
that kind of headline by the way we know
that americans
rarely read down into an article i think
that that is around 60 or 70 percent of
people only read the headline and then
the remainder of that is only the first
paragraph so very i think three or five
percent people actually read the whole
story so these folks know that i want to
give a shout out to a journalist this is
a story i i did i covered
just almost three years ago i remember
this from business insider this
journalist wrote i tried to buy a gun at
walmart twice and roadblocks left me
empty empty-handed both times
this was actually a good story and i
give credit to this journalist she had
um you know misconceptions about what
buying a gun was like she went to a
walmart and said i'm gonna see what
happens and when she got road blocked
she wrote that she was good for her this
is like one of the biggest segments i've
ever done it's got 2.7 million views i
i'm surprised but
you know i i didn't criticize her and le
mancha i was like this is great a
reporter actually decided to investigate
what it's like to get guns because they
weren't familiar with it and they were
honest with their audience about not
being able to buy one
that's that's the reality yeah the the
shocking thing about courts is that
there are
two dozen outlets just like that right
between
courts and axios and mother jones and
and you just go on and on and on and
they're all they're all the same and
they're all funded by basically the same
venture capitalist lefty ideologue
billionaires they all have the same
agenda they're all intermarried right
which is weird they're all they all know
each other kind of like the uh um the
the one conspiracy nah that conspiracy
the one thought is who the leaker is of
the supreme court document when went
through of you know who's married to who
and who was a bridesmaid and who's
waiting they all know each other um it's
a cast system there's no one on there
there are very few outlets on the right
of this side there are a couple right we
know them the beacon the daily caller
they're great publications but they're
they're they're paltry in number
compared to right left and
you look at the the the funding that
goes into these
left-wing democrat or whatever
publications hundreds of millions of
dollars and then you look at right-wing
publications who sometimes get some
funding but not really yeah what was
that cia program where uh they were
working directly with media was that was
that mockingbird yeah yeah i think it is
it's like yeah there's two of them i'm
pretty sure i thought you were asking me
about the time that we uh operated on
the cat and the cat was going to be
actually a listening device
that's another one is that that's a real
thing that is that is true they tried we
did that and
yes so this is what they did they
actually put the the the listening
device in the ear and then they use the
antenna and they built another part in
the back kind of in between the
shoulders and they what they did is they
took the cat because hey it's just a cat
it's innocuous and they took the cat and
they uh they set it next to two
gentlemen to test it on a park bench i
know what happened i think and
unfortunately kitty kitty did not stay
there of course not to
listen so the cat
ran
unfortunately in front of a taxi oh no
oh my gosh
cat didn't want to be part of it nope
the kitty kitty for the cat did not
survive ultimate sacrifice
you can't
speaking of mockingbird which i brought
up um
what the heck this is from 1948 i mean
this has been going on for a long time
the cia basically right after formation
was like we've got to control the media
it's not just mockingbird we talked
about this with luke uh rodkowski if we
are change there was something that
happened in the 70s where a senator i
think came out and said the cia is
working directly at these news outlets
yeah
do you don't know
well so there was a huge dust up
throughout the 70s where basically the
the the house and the senate were like
you guys are doing way too much that you
in the cia and they had committee
hearings so frank church was one of the
senators leave from idaho and there were
others they looked into this and the cia
director they called him on the carpet
both overtly that is to say out in
public and then and behind the curtain
and like you guys are killing way too
many people uh without authorization and
you know a bunch of cowboys and some of
these uh programs that you're talking
about we're part of that conversation
that we need to rein you in because
we've given you too much power and y'all
are abusing it and it's not just you the
cia it's the president and all the
president's men as it were who were like
hey you know with the military we can't
do certain things but we can use this
tool at the cia and we can have them go
kill various people or foment on rising
uprisings etc right or yes the media
piece we can start to control and
manipulate and so again it gets back to
this if you give people power some
percentage of them are going to abuse it
but if you give them a whole bunch of
power it is game on in terms of your
country and that's really for me in the
past five ten years has completely
changed my understanding of giving so
much power to the cia or nsa or fbi they
will abuse it they have abused it and
we've got to pull that back both in
terms of the size and the authorities
because they have too much still a lot
of great people doing great work at
those places but you give them too much
power and you're going to have these
problems and our country's in trouble
because of it yeah i think a lot about
the people because i i speak a lot of
crap about the administrative state and
like how it's overblown but i think the
people the other night i was like i
don't want to hurt these people like not
that like the the horseback riders in
1902 i mean the automobile was coming
they still lost their jobs yeah
i don't want to see these people lose
their gigs and the problem is when
they're the ones that control the
assassination attempts so anyone that's
going to try and unseat them from their
gig is a is real threat
has a big like yo you don't want to
anger people that control the button
like
basically but
if it is i mean
you think we'd be better better off
without
these organizations i think i think of
the fed in michigan who's who's doing a
covert op and he's on a chat room with
some guy he was like i hate governor
whitman i think we should assassinate
her and he's like let's play and let's
plan the kidnapping you know and then
they're having meetings and then all of
a sudden at no point people like wait a
second we're actually gonna plan to
kidnap the governor just to trap this
one loot aren't we taking this a little
too far guys
you know they're they're ordering vans
and someone's going to hurts and they're
picking up a rope and it's like i think
we're getting a little too excited about
kidnapping the governor guys like i know
we want to catch this bad dude but
this is getting a little crazy i i so
i don't at what point does yeah when you
say they need to be reined in i think
that's an example of reining it in and
it kind of strikes me bizarre that no
one in the hierarchy was like i think
you guys need to slow down the
kidnapping plan
this is a little crazy would it look
more like if it was raining in would it
be like this this nsa no longer exists
like what was the nsa form 2000 2001 was
it after 911 or has it been around
longer than that it's been around longer
but yeah look i here's where i come down
on this i think it's absolutely
reasonable based on what we have seen
over the past 10 plus years certainly
since the the 2016 election it's
reasonable for people to say
the the intelligence community has grown
too big and too powerful
just like it did back in the 1970s we
need to remove some of the authorities
we need to have more oversight because
we recognize that there might be a need
for collection of foreign intelligence
to understand what our adversaries are
doing fine or a domestic
law enforcement capacity we need to find
some bad guys here in the country
fine
but it's gotten too big and there's too
much power and we need to pull that back
in and that happens after we have the
house and the senate if they actually
functioned they would do the
investigations into that to figure out
how bad the problem is and then we
figure out how deeply we have to rein it
in absent a functional congress
that's when the the american media is
supposed to do the work do that
investigative work to expose some of
this stuff but when you have a media
that is so in the tank
for you know folks particularly on the
left
then what what's their incentive to
actually get to the bottom of some of
these abuses that's there's no outside
function right now that's keeping power
in check
the house the senate nope the president
nope our media nope that's the problem
of this moment and i think it's
compounded by the fact that
no offense you all seem to be really bad
at your job i mean in the sense that
it's like well not
our intelligence shows that you know
afghanistan will stand on its own no our
intelligence shows that that kiev will
fall within three days no it's like our
intelligence shows like do you guys have
anything right like is there anything
that that is accurate okay first of all
poorly fair so i so on my podcast
president's daily brief we covered this
we talked about this you as a taxpayers
are paying
billions and billions of dollars to the
intelligence community to act on your
behalf you should be asking questions if
they're falling short so that's fair
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you